This is looking at search traffic, the mobile
search traffic that hits Google.
And if you look at the proportion that comes
from HTML5-capable browsers, it's far outpacing
the other browsers as well.
So HTML5 is everywhere.
So the question is, how do we make use of
it?
How do we all make use of it to create amazing
experiences for users?
So I want to show you a few examples.
I'm going to start with a demo from Google.
I'm going to invite Jeff Chang, who's a product
manager on the Chrome team, to give you a
demo of GMail, how GMail is has built two
simple yet powerful features on top of HTML5.
So let's get started.
So Jeff is loading GMail.
It turns out, one of the most popular features
in GMail is sending e-mail.
[ Laughter ]
>>Sundar Pichai: And most people tend to attach
files when they do that.
If you're using a traditional desktop application
like outlook, it's very intuitive.
You just drag and drop a file.
That's been hard for Web applications to do.
But now, using the HTML5 file APIs, he can
drag that photo very intuitively and just
drop it in GMail.
Simple, but very powerful.
What most users do in their day-to-day lives.
A second such example is around notifications.
It's very common for you to be in a Web application
which has notifications associated with it.
For example, Google Chat is built into GMail.
The question is, how do you receive that notification
when you are not on GMail?
So but now using the HTML5 notifications Gmail
-- notifications API, Jeff can receive the
e-mail from Bob, I guess, even when he is
not on GMail.
So two examples.
The file API and notifications API, and GMail
is implementing to deliver powerful features
to our users.
So at this pointed, I would like to invite
-- we want to show you real-world examples,
people all over the community building great
applications on top of HTML5.
So I would like to invite first Charles Pritchard
from MugTug, and Jim Lanzone from Clicker.com.
[ Applause ]
>>Charles Pritchard: Hello, everyone.
My name's Charles Pritchard.
I'm the CEO behind MugTug.
I've come here to preview our latest software
development.
It's an application we call Darkroom.
In 2006, Michael Deal and I created an HTML
4 Web site called MugTug Studio.
It used cloud services to allow people to
edit their images, apply effects, et cetera.
It was slow, and it used a lot of bandwidth.
But now, this year, with HTML5 support growing,
we're able to bring MugTug Darkroom onto the
client side.
Now, when I say "client side," I mean that
we're untethered, we're not connected to the
Internet, or at least we don't need to be.
I'm going to go ahead and unplug and show
you that, indeed, we are offline, unless the
Wi-Fi, of course, picks up.
So we're offline.
And we are still in the cache.
The way this is done is by using some HTML5
APIs.
One of them is application cache.
We also use local storage and the file reader.
Our GUI is in canvas 2D context.
So I'm going to go ahead, and I'm going to
start using the application.
You can see here, we have a few beautiful
photos.
And these are all being served from the local
computer.
But what I'd like to do is go ahead and work
with one that hasn't been touched up yet.
That's going to be this one right here.
Experts amongst you will notice a few things
wrong with this photo.
It's tilted.
So I'm going to go ahead and I'm going to
apply our advanced rotate effect.
Very wild, I know.
And the next thing we're going to do here
is, you can tell that the camera flash has
brought out that infamous red eye effect.
[ Laughter ]
>>Charles Pritchard: So I'm going to go ahead
here, and I'm going to give him a much more
natural appearance.
It's much better, much better.
Anyway, what you do see here is the next generation
of application.
It's quick to load, quick to close, and quick
to use.
I'm previewing it on the latest Google Chrome,
which has great support for HTML5.
The application itself is using JavaScript,
and it's using the canvas 2D context for its
GUI.
We're going to see a lot more of these in
the future, because HTML5 support, offline
applications are being actively championed
by every major browser vendor.
Again, my name is Charles Pritchard.
This is MugTug Darkroom.
And I invited you to visit us in the sandbox
if you'd like some more information or if
you'd just like to play around with some of
the other image effects we have going on.
Thank you.
[ Applause ]
>>Jim Lanzone: So we launched Clicker.com
a few months ago, it's been called the TV
guide for the Web.
It's essentially a massive database, like
sites like Trip Advisor or Yelp.
But it's focused just on the premium programming
available on the Web across Web originals,
broadcast television, movie, music videos.
Because it's no longer about when things are
on or having a scheduled grid.
It's about where they're on and whether they're
on and what you can actually get across thousands
of different hosts of online video.
So we launched a few months ago, and a lot
of our users are actually just broadcasting
their PC screens up to their televisions or
using a Mac mini to do so.
And Clicker.com was definitely geared toward
the two-foot experience.
It's a Web site.
They've wanted to be able to use us in that
ten-foot experience.
We're here today to launch clicker.TV, which
is our ten-foot experience.
You see us kind of moving through T you'll
see it looks and feels a lot like a downloadable
application or a plug-in or something you
might have to buy a box to attach to your
TV.
But it's native to the browser.
You go to Clicker.TV to use it.
It does this thanks in part to HTML5, using
Canvas, Web worker threads, the local storage
API, and, of course, it really hums in a browser
like Chrome.
Even though it works in all browsers, it really
shines.
And you see the speed of this application.
We'll see -- let's go into, let's say, a show.
Start with "Charlie Rose."
That's an example I like to use.
And you'll see it appears, you don't have
to go to the search box.
Chrome likes to show itself off.
And you'll see all the Charlie Rose episodes
that have been online going back to 1994,
all organized by season.
Another example, let's say with my kids I
want to watch this online show called "Pigeon
Impossible," which is a Pixar-like short.
I start typing "pigeon," hit it, and I get
to the actual show page.
Perhaps.
Like Bill Gates.
Just hit enter and I just hit play.
[ Music ]
>>Jim Lanzone: Let's say instead I want to
watch, actually, broadcast television.
We don't host all programming.
To be the TV guide of the Web, you have to
be truly comprehensive and unbiased across
everything, even things you don't host.
Let's maybe, for example, go back to the home
page and try the show "lost."
I'm not sure how many of you were watching
that 12 hours ago, like I was, hoping finally
someone would ask a follow-up question.
I'm still waiting for that after six years.
Let's say we want to watch the episode that's
online.
Again, just go to the show, hit enter, you
get to the show.
In this case, you're being taken to ABC's
Web site and it comes up large screen to play,
or you can hit full screen to get it all the
way there.
But, again, very easy and on your keyboard
just hit the back space or delete button and
you get back to the programming guide.
Maybe because I don't want to watch the ad,
I want to add it to my play list you see on
the left-hand side I can scroll down or add
to my play list and then down the left-hand
side of the page, I can go into the play list
using the arrow keys or the configured remote.
You see all these shows I have saved.
On our site here is "Deadliest Warrior."
If anyone has seen this show, it's ridiculous,
like watching Alexander the Great square off
against Attila the Hun.
So I've saved all these things.
You can also then browse 1400 categories in
TV, movies, Web originals.
You can even sort by themes, kind of like
Pandora, like jeans, like, quirky characters
and things like that.
And you see the movie page.
You can just go straight into Netflix, if
you're a subscriber, to watch.
So that's Clicker.TV, again, purely native.
You just go to that Web site, and very, very
rich, thanks in large patient to HTML5 and
the guys at Chrome.
We are in the sandbox, and we'd love to see
you guys there.
Thanks for having us.
Have a great next couple of days.
Thanks.
[ Applause ]
>>Sundar Pichai: So it's great to see these
applications.
We will have many more on the way.
And these are all built on HTML5 and work
great in the browser.